RUSSIANS.
WHITE HOUSE SAYING IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT.
HICKS HAD PLANNED TO RESIGN FOR
SOME TIME AND HAS INFORMED THE
PRESIDENT.
TONIGHT WE TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
THE SECURITY CLEARANCE SITUATION
INVOLVING THE PRESIDENT'S
SON-IN-LAW AND SENIOR ADVISOR.
CORRESPONDENT GILLIAN TURNER
REPORTS ON WHAT HAPPENS NOW
AFTER THE ACCESS DOWNGRADE FOR
JARED KUSHNER.
>> NOTHING THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE
WILL AFFECT THE VALUABLE WORK
JARED IS DOING.
>> SENIOR OFFICIALS CLAIM JARED
KUSHNER'S FOREIGN POLICY
PORTFOLIO ISN'T IN JEOPARDY NOW
THAT HE HAS LOST HIS TOP-SECRET
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
THEY ALSO INSIST HIS EFFORTS TO
BROKER A MIDEAST PEACE DEAL
WON'T BE IMPACTED.
>> I CAN'T SEE ANY CHANGE ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT.
OR HIS WORK ON THAT ISSUE.
>> FORMER SENIOR NATIONAL
SECURITY OFFICIALS IN THE BUSH
AND OBAMA ADMINISTRATIONS DOW
FOX NEWS KUSHNER'S DOWNGRADE
FROM TOP-SECRET TO JUST SECRET
WILL IMPACT HIS ABILITY TO DO
HIS JOB.
THEY SAY HE WILL NO LONGER HAVE
ACCESS TO THE NATION'S MOST
SENSITIVE INFORMATION.
IN ADDITION TO BEING BARRED FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DAILY
INTELLIGENCE BRIEFING, KUSHNER
MAY BE EXCLUDED FROM NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL MEETINGS IN
WHICH HE IS SUPPOSED TO PLAY A
KEY ROLE.
>> THEY ARE USUALLY CONDUCTED AT
THE TOP-SECRET LEVEL.
THEY WILL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WORKAROUND.
OR EXCLUDE HIM FROM PORTIONS OF
SOME OF THE MEETINGS.
>> KUSHNER WON'T BE ABLE TO SEE
TOP-SECRET INTELLIGENCE
GENERATED BY THE CIA AND THE
NSA.
INFORMATION LIKE THE REAL NAMES
LOCATIONS AND METHODS OF
AMERICAN SPIES IN FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
INFORMATION THAT INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY INSIDERS REFER TO AS
THE CROWN JEWEL BECAUSE OF THEIR
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH VALUE.
ONE SENIOR NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT BUSH SAYS
THE PRIMARY JOB OF A FOREIGN
POLICY ADVISOR IS TO TAKE A
VAST, SOMETIMES OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION AND
DISTILL IT FOR THE PRESIDENT.
NOW WITH HIS ACCESS TO
INFORMATION SEVERELY LIMITED,